bien le bonjour petit insecte comment
vas tu aujourd'hui on va s'exercer à
baisser ces insectes qui nous empêche de
dormir par exemple en était même en
hiver les bonnes araignée tu s'est
accroché au plafond tout à fait certain
philippe et tu ouvres les yeux tu vois
un gros truc comme ça ça fait flipper
attend dirait un mauvais podcast là ce
qui se passe je sais pas si vous avez
déjà remarqué lorsque vous vous
réveillez moi je vais prendre mon
insectes customiser à customiser
tournant c'est que mon customiser une
voiture finalement exactement j'ai hâte
de le voir donc le bémol compris c'est
le jeu trouve yann et que je lui baisent
sa grosse gueule et que j'aime c'est
aussi alors est ce que peux tu es tu
peux me dire ce que c'est un secteur où
lors pourquoi parler comme ça mais je
sais pas on est un tueur elle voilà mes
mecs mais attendez donc tu fais la
taille de mes pieds
j'ai customiser et honte tu fais là bien
là bien que c'est un bon pote ça alors
c'est la chasse avant attention pic ne
touche pas un évène mon pote mais vaine
m'appartiennent béria tu commets pas
légiste a ajouté vu ce postier buste
projeté du spawn je vais te buter j'aime
pas ce bruit je pense que oui marivaux
ou bien le regarde bien j'ai gagné je
suis hyper content je suis hyper content
ça va changer ma vie et mon nombre de
vue surtout bon nombre de vue d'ailleurs
est ce que tu me laisses pimp aimons
insectes avec grand plaisir je dis merci
yann insectes tabac voici la sec que je
viens de pimp et c'est une sorte de
coccinelles avec un avant de scorpions
et des ailes d'aigle où nous nous sommes
dans un métro je suis un microbe parmi
les microbes h veut pas voler on est
d'accord que c'est la musique de harry
potter
j'ai fait la sec le plus nul à ch mais
ce soit là le truc qui vient d'australie
mais il a survécu 24 heures apparemment
il était en disparition direct insectes
hockey lnah je propose une abeille avec
une tête de souris cette fois j'espère
bien volé et te percer les oreilles tu
vas me chercher bien loin non en fait tu
vois tu as tout de mayotte pendant très
longtemps à la rue apache a tort c'est
quoi je vais dire j'ai dit à ne pas
perdre on joue dans mon jacuzzi je suis
posé sur ma paroisse envers al aryane on
tourne en bourrique cas ça ne perde tous
cas expression de violence que ce soit
un petit peu vieille a drapé une au
tournage trop merde racontage bernatchez
kadrige et ta femme en otage yann a pas
plus et je lui touche att au maire de
viane j'ai ton petit ami en otage ne
fait pas sa yam aubin ça je m'en fous je
les cheveux retenus vétérans j'arrête de
boire du thé ja on vous a vu les buveurs
de thé comme un niveau très de c est ce
qu on a le même moi même je vois des
petites et je vais pas te mentir à
[ __ ] à souris
voilà je vais poser c'est génial alors
je mets à temps il a demandé non non non
olalala judicieusement princesse allons
tuer la vie au volant nous avons ya
vraiment parce que je sais pas si vous
êtes déjà marqué un but à chauffailles
d'autres classes et voilà je dis oui
mais continuez continuez à l'appel de
points qu'ils allaient le petit dernier
non non non non non non non je te pique
à témoin au cedar ce que tu as fait
débat a bien ouais bon j'ai tenté un
truc j'ai tenté ça va être mon chien
bien dans la critique désabonnez vous il
est beau aussi la ans qu'il est beau tu
va l'adorer
ce qui peut voler ouais ils volent venus
je crois que là on vient de la jeunesse
a marqué mais l'escargot ainsi que
l'escalier sont en forme d'escargot
c'est nul c nul à chier sd j'espère vous
êtes des abonnés en tout cas ne faisait
plus de doute vous devez faire un nom
mais je n'ai pas marqué mais ces
escaliers en forme d'escargot
ça ressemble à des escargots je poste a
remarqué mais plus d'affichage ne
répondait plus à été récupérés la gaine
d'après le perso de vienne est évoqué
mais ta bouche en tout cas c'est très
stable c'est si agréable je sais pas
s'ils ont déjà remarqué
ok elle me dit pas tout bien sûr ne pas
bouger sinon je marchais toi je te base
c'est bon je veux bouger
ok annonce jean rivière là bas non je
peux pas marquer viendra boire du thé à
jouer puisqu'il est plus mais alors là
je judicieusement placé encore une fois
c'est vrai non j'arrive pas à manger du
bon gars comment les élèves voilées aux
cdc qui pique comme ça calmement
j'aimerais refaire l'un de la
bibliothèque mais mais j'aimerais tous
chassés comme ta mère quant à ut 18 ans
d'accord on a dit qu'on parle pas de la
vie personnelle
la petite est pas fait face à teddy
tamgho pas du tout tout est un fils à
papa thomas noël une voiture est bien
caché voila voila j'ai trouvé la voie là
parce que moi à noël j'avais une orange
et j'étais bien content d'aller dans le
saloon allez mon nom et ma crie alors
michael stone secteur maggie may cry pas
mac custom à très très drôle
alors ok tu es mignon tuer tout mignon
jan on dirait un petit chien ce que tu
as pas vite
rien du tout voilà on emballe plus tu
fais une abeille
ouais mais santa ana vrac le cendrier
bien sûr on en est là aujourd'hui sur la
chaîne de squeeze en 2016 je te vois pas
t'es où la grosse patte dans ton cul a
maintenant des musiques de desperate
housewives
ouais n'est pas facile la poste a
remarqué mais quand tu craches la fois
d'affilée à prêter un peu saoulé je peux
prendre la vieille femme avec des seins
absolument dégueulasse alors j'aimerais
qu'ils apprennent pas mais c'est super
long ça merci ma famille on est très
contentes
je peux savoir qu aimer les 22 bond de 5
ça fait toujours rire j'étais pas
touchés et bah là mais moi par contre je
n'ai touché et je parle pas d'eux des
dab sommeil warm up
voilà j'ai le trophée pas sous ma jupe
non je n'ai pas envie d'être sous ta
jupe parce que ça fait 35 ans que
personne est allé voir tu avait convoqué
au bureau du directeur vient au peuple
alors la tâche ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas entendu touch
merci mamie elle a des bras cm quoi
c'est un t-rex mon gars tu passes ta
remarque est mais mamie elle est nul à
chier je vais te prouver que la
grand-mère
bien que peu séduisante n'est pas si nul
que tu le penses déjà dans la check up
la hâte et a voulu balaye les nuls en
est assez mince et maël ont du vécu mon
cas ils ont touché des choses tu n'as
pas idée longtemps que t'as pas vu à
tarnaby 1
[Musique]
elle m'a appelée et bastien pour ça a au
nom plus sympas du nord bien joué je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
c'est la fin de cette vidéo
tu te laisses tes pas à vous abonner à
la chaîne de yann c'est du bon contenu
une fois par an c'est vrai abonnez vous
lâcher triade portez vous bien du monde
a dit papy ce nom faisait remarquer mais
c'était mieux avant